Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is Rawkode slash David, and I'm
your host for today's episode of cluster.
It's been a little while, but we're gonna
have a lot of fun taking two very
broken and Kubernetes clusters and doing our best
to fix them.
Today is solo edition, and I am joined
by Hans and Zach. Hello, How are you
doing?
Hi, David.
Alright.
Well, thank you both for joining me. I'm
really excited that we get to do another
episode of cluster today. So if we could
just start with you, Hans, and then Zach,
say hello and tell us a little bit
about yourself.
Hi. I'm Hans.
I work as a platform engineer for the
Norwegian Labor and Welfare Administration.
Been using Kubernetes for quite some time, but
really
excited for today. I haven't fixed much broken
much of these broken clusters so this would
be cool.
Yeah. Alright. And hi. I'm Zach. I work
for Microsoft.
My team at Microsoft works on, you know,
deploying Kubernetes in all the places that isn't,
you know, the public Azure cloud. And, you
know, we call ourselves, like, the AKS Edge
team, and we do a lot of exciting
things. And we deal with a lot of
broken clusters. So
I'm excited to, you know, share some of
my learnings and fix one live. So yep.
Well, yeah, let's face it. It is not
difficult to break Kubernetes.
So
No.
I I I say that leaving a cluster
to its own self for, you know, a
week or two without touching it, it it's
gonna it's gonna go bad. It's like, you
know, it's like the gremlins.
Well, yeah, because we have this little lynchpin
in Kubernetes called NCT, which cannot really go
uncatered for un nurtured and uncared for. So,
yeah, always fun, always a challenge. But it
just means that when we come on to
episodes of custard like this, you know, I
always tell people the hardest part is probably
deciding how to break it. Right? Right? How
did you both find that? Like like, there's
a million and one ways and yet you
can't seem to think of what you like.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Sort of I've I've broken my fair share
of clusters, but once I sort of oh,
yeah. Forty eight hours to really break this
cluster here. I just totally froze. But luckily,
I do have some good buddies that
so made
made the thinking go a little bit smoother.
Oh, yeah. Exactly. I mean, I just as
soon as I told everyone, I am gonna
be on the show, they were like, oh,
like, remember this time we looked at a
cluster that where that happened and when that
happened, then, you know, using guy like that
back, like, that past experience of, like, seeing
some, you know, messed up clusters. I was
like, how can I do that on purpose?
Awesome. Well, we are about to find out.
So
this is how clustered works. One,
I share my screen here.
We have Teleport.
Teleport is a tool that will allow us
to all access the same machines at the
same time typing in the same terminal,
which means we can try and fix these
clusters together.
Teleport also sponsor clusters, so thank you very
much to Teleport.
Also, all these machines run on bare metal.
They've got a healthy amount of CPUs, a
healthy amount of RAM, and that is all
thanks to Equinix Medal who also sponsor. Well,
thank you both for providing the tools that
make this possible.
We are gonna start with Zach control plane
one. That means hands,
you're fixing first.
I have opened the session. You should be
able to see it on the active sessions
list. If you could please join and just
type echo or hello or your name, anything,
but let us know that we are in.
It's joining here and it says access denied.
Disconnected,
actually.
Oh, dear.
Could I
let's refresh and join one more time
because it shows up here
twenty six seconds ago.
Still disconnected now.
You know, we got this last time, and
I forgot all about it.
So
let's see if I can fix the helper.
The problem was the no. I did update
it here.
Game of the role.
Oh, but this is the join that's broken.
Alright. Let's do it the other way. Can
you open a session, please?
So if I connect
Yeah. I think you're just missing the join
permission, so I'm gonna try and join.
Okay.
So I'll
joining the control play one. Yep.
I've joined.
So it's a challenge accepted. We have sort
of broken teleport.
No?
I I didn't touch teleport.
No.
You know what? It's just been so long
since I did a and we did run
into this on the last episode, and I
100%
forgot that we have the problem. Now it's
not the end of the world, and
I can always do the typing if required,
but I'm wondering if we can fix this.
I bet we can. Yep. Because we have
the rule editor here,
and there's an editor rule, which if I
copy,
grab all of this.
Or I could just get myself editor role,
couldn't I?
Leasing in the teleport
tweak.
Perhaps. We have to expand the scope of
the show from clustered up.
Technology.
There's sort of a there were three simple
rules. It was sort of, like, don't break
the bootloader,
don't exhaust the disk, and don't break teleport.
Yep.
Alright.
Let's
copy all this.
Look at our.
That's a camel.
Let's try again.
Resources are under road.
This is why we want something like Q
instead of YAML when you're writing configurations.
I feel like Q.
No. I I haven't used it enough to
make sort of a good time.
Let's not debug that. I'll just
I'll do the type in for you.
Because oh, I mean,
you could share your screen if you want.
I mean, this is solo edition. Are you
happy to share your screen?
I'm more than happy to share my screen.
No worries. Alright. Awesome. You share your screen.
Let's do it that way. Okay. Maybe I'll
try and fix teleport in the background so
we can have it working later. But let's
just do the screen share from there.
Okay. It's Very professional and sort of cluster.
You can see all over this.
Google Chrome is required for screen sharing then.
Give me some I'll I'll just take that.
Okay.
Yep.
Okay. So let's see what we have here.
I'm just going to expand this image here
so I can actually see.
Alright. Well, well, you can expand it by
right clicking essential controls. It's very hidden by
my streaming software, but it is there.
So I have exported the KubeConfig for you.
These are Kube admin clusters, which means that
we are able to use admin dot cov
to be able to speak to the Kubernetes
control plane. Okay.
Cool. So let's
do sort of let's do a kubectl version
just to see if we sort of are
able to
oh, and it says the oh, the connection
was refused.
That IP there doesn't really look right.
From my recollection, it should have been sort
of more
of
a local private IP. So let's go ahead
and and look into that admin conference, see
what we are dealing with there.
Okay. So I'm flashing Kubernetes credentials to the
world.
Yeah.
Maybe not the
Anyone that could copy off these x five
zero nine is good for them. Exactly.
Oh, man.
Yeah. So that's
I I sort of I really believe that
that IP there shouldn't look like like that.
If you could bring up IF config and
just look at the
what was the
yep.
So Looks good to me.
Oh, yeah. Okay. But there's internal address
as well.
Okay.
Yeah. So it's it's definitely there.
Let's see. Can we
okay. So
is
Kubelet even running? What does
John Oll CTL says for the Kubelet?
Running? By then? It's just material. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely.
What does it say here? Unable to write
event. So probably it's not able to same
as us, not able to connect to the
API
server.
Let's do
let's check if there's any containers in the
in the
k s I o namespace,
the CTR.
And it's is it containers
LS?
Okay. So I see I see an API
server at least.
Can we
how do we get the logs for this
then?
I don't recall if there were any logs
output directly from the CTR.
We could use CTR.
But because we're on this machine, I tend
to just use bar log.
Mhmm. Yeah.
I also like cry cry cuddle.
Yeah.
So
we have Cilium, CoreDNS.
We have the Kube API server over here.
And then
If we have more than one.
Yeah.
And
is it complaining about it city?
I don't recall if I saw any.
It says
it's a retrying.
Zach would have to be very cruel to
mess with Etsyd.
Yeah.
No one really knows Edcity.
Dialing temp socket file connection, no such final
directory.
Would would that would that be too cruel
for the game?
No.
But I have pulled our previous
guest slash victims on Cluster before. And the
number one thing, almost unanimously,
that people do not want to see broken
is that to be
So the definitely something here. Address connection, create
transport, fail to connect to, and then it
says temp socket file dot sock. So
dialing Unix. So it's trying to connect to
a socket.
So
to my
that's
suspect here, right? Yeah, yeah.
Somehow,
sort of the Kube API server is trying
to connect to a socket here. So
we need to look at the manifest files
for the Kube API
and see what's going on over there. Which
manifest would you like to look at?
It is a it's it is a Kubernetes
manifest
there, and there should be a Kube API
server
with their We can be modified.
Let's
look at that one.
So we do have the advertised
there.
And
let's see here. Can I move my
the
it says servers,
so it does
has
do you have an address there? I don't
see
any socket
sort of
configurations
It would indicate that it's trying to
connect to a socket
yet.
Signing
TLS
encryption provider.
This looks
looks normal.
I say that all the time, but, you
know, what the heck?
Dave David sees it.
It's it's it's it's Oh,
I need I need to squint more with
my eyes here, and
let's see what have I missed here.
There's one thing here you just you probably
wanna cast your eye on for sure.
Okay.
Sorry.
Maybe if I just move my cursor.
And is is that the one encryption
encryption provider config?
Because I know.
I mean,
I don't remember enabling encryption on RTD.
So
Oh, man.
Yeah.
Encryption provider config. No. That's
yeah. I Let's take a look at it.
Right. Yeah. Let's let's do that.
Something tells me we're not done in that
fail. But
Okay.
So
Hello?
I'll let you you could tell us. What
do we see?
So there's the socket file at least. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah.
So
in my sort of simple hand, sort of
what if we just remove this from the
from the
Kube API server?
Yeah. I guess
we're we're about to find out just how
cruel that has been. Right? Like, did he
even encrypt anything? Is it just a pseudo
misdirection?
Oh, man. I don't like it. But we
could we could certainly comment that for now.
Mhmm.
Yeah.
Angel's scan.
Oh, no. How have I lost David's trust
so quickly? It's because I came late to
the
because I came late to the the pre
the pre show.
Alright. What are you thinking, Hans?
Just comment to oh, and let's let's see
what happens?
Yeah. That's that's tested out at least.
Of course, if it's
if it's already encrypted and we need to
we need some keys to decrypt it, then
we need to figure out where the keys
are.
Well, we'll give that a moment to restart.
We can maybe nudge it with restarting the
Qplet, but we'll give it thirty seconds.
There it goes.
And it's back.
Alright.
Okay. What's your next play?
Well, we need to look at the logs
again.
And
I think we are still
unable to speak to Edcity.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
So what does it actually
say here?
Request timed out.
Is it a connection error?
Connection to the
cluster.
Now let's
was
running?
I didn't recall if we
if that's
So Appears. Here.
Yeah.
Might be worse to be running. Yeah. Just
run kubectl get pods and see if
yeah. Okay.
Can you just tell us to run that
to make us
Who?
Oh, it responded.
Slowly.
Faster than that.
Interesting.
Yeah. My my
sort of
my my video is sort of blocking the
lower part of the screen, so it's a
little bit hard to see the
the Well, it would appear that cube control
get stuff
work.
Somewhat work.
Definitely slow.
That's suspicious.
Maybe I was seeing her.
Oh, wow. Hand that time out, so there's
definitely something
some
did get the pods.
I can get services too.
You need services.
Alright. Well, I mean, the objective is to
get clustered v two deployed. Yep. Maybe you
can from this position.
Okay. Let's let's see if we have the
deployment even though we don't have the pod.
But
That's
interesting.
Yeah. Let's go ahead and describe that.
Definitely something funky going on since it's,
is this slow.
Yeah. Something's not quite right.
It got there.
Okay.
It's one unavailable.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's interesting.
That,
let's look at the replica sets.
That's
So I think this
guess is a good indication
of some behavior here. So you
wanna
what Can we I would I'm just can
you do a rollout
restart on the deployment?
I mean, I could delete deployments pretty easily,
but rollouts? Come on.
Come on. He pay he pays by the
the keynote.
Alright.
Okay. Let's do get deployed
RF
Mhmm.
So we have
no change.
So, yeah, I think this confirms my
my thoughts here.
I can share, but I'll give you an
opportunity to kinda
Is there something going on with our KubeCTL
binary? So just can you do a which
KubeCTL?
That's not a lot of trust, Hans.
And I can see what's the output because
that line is blocked by my window. But
It looks like we have cube control at
the right location as l 64 bit compiled
statically like binary.
So Yeah.
It looks
alright.
I'm not gonna say it looks good. I'm
gonna say it looks alright.
Just to be sure, can we just use
that
slash user bin kubectl kubectl
and then get pods just to make sure
that it's
not something else messing with the kubectl,
not an alias or anything?
Okay. Yeah. So the same same result there.
So
I think
that we have a working a semi working
API server to the point where it is
returning data, and we can get pods deployment,
the scrape, etcetera. However,
the API server legally isn't being updated,
which means the kubilant maybe isn't functioning as
we expect. Okay. We're able to actually report
back that our pod is no longer
running. Even though it's not listed under get
pods, I'm a bit confused. But I feel
like we've got some
disconnect there that we probably wanna track then.
Okay. So we need to check the Qubelet
logs then. I mean, listening to me comes
with its own risk, but
It's in a server request
time out.
Air syncing pod, faintly start continue. So, yeah,
faintly update status.
Crash the backup.
So cube
cube controller,
let's
let's see if we can
get the logs for the
the controller manager.
Mhmm.
I'd say that's
mostly as expected.
Yeah.
Would you expect it to lose leader election?
Oh, no. I never saw that thing.
Oh, yeah.
But there's not one healthy line in that
log.
Yeah. We got a
yeah. Okay. Her error retrieving resource
lock. Yeah. Everything there is broken.
I think we should just do a, you
know, keep call, get pods. Oh, let's just
see, like, how everything everything's sailing around.
Oh, yeah. Nothing worked.
So at least okay. So our controller manager
and scheduler isn't
isn't working.
Yeah. We can't even control the manager. I
don't care about the scheduler, but we do
need the Yeah.
And
the only
to
renew lease,
queue control timed out waiting for
condition.
So it's the
leases.
I know there is this lease
object,
but I
have no idea really what it's
the cube node and
control manager,
but
really don't know what
I'll just say, like, let's think about Yeah.
You know, every command is pretty slow.
The pod can't grab its leader election in
time.
So how would you slow down
workloads on a Linux machine?
Are they most of these are containers.
Maybe
you should inspect them.
Yep.
Is there
something
sort of are they
sort of resource
constrained?
Are they
Well, there's one container.
So let's do
that that
that control
one.
I would say, yeah, I think there was
a path where you were on the right
one earlier on when we're focusing more on,
like, core components here.
Yeah.
Who would ever mess with ECT?
Very much of us like it when you
talk, Zach.
It's a it's a it's a Halloween special.
A haunted cluster.
Definitely a haunted cluster.
Yeah. So, yeah, so something is making it
behave
really, really slow.
Snapshot count.
Experiment experimental
watch progress notify
interval.
Yeah. Those look I really don't know if
those are normal.
Yeah. Yeah. Maybe it's, like, the logs.
Well, those two flags are, like, weird.
Let's follow Zach's advice to check a log.
Well, just
I don't know if they'll yeah.
Let's do this
one.
Did I get wrong there?
Oh, no. I copied it.
I totally just blew it out loud, didn't
I?
No.
Hold on. I'm just gonna make it harder
for you, Hans.
Yeah. Because that's the most recent recent one.
Right?
But
that was
unhelpful.
Yeah.
Maybe maybe logs aren't helpful. Sorry.
We do have a slow It's the data
sync here.
Apply request took too long.
Well, that
doesn't look great.
Defunct.
No.
Good.
Do you mind if I kill it? Yeah.
Let's do that.
The funk the zombie is definitely not gonna
go away now.
But I try I thought I'd try.
Oh, is this something? It is. Yeah.
I
think that's an old
maybe the process name isn't
might be s a s a d. I
think that might be an old, because I'm
beat anyway.
Alright.
Let's make a small change to this.
I'm gonna suggest that we comment these two
experiment and flags out. Just a to force
f c z to restart the the Kubernetes
to restart it, but also just because
I don't I don't like the side of
them. So
Are you happy with that?
Yeah. That's The other thing just not that
I have this wonderful cheat sheet that I
always use.
Super.
It tells us how to configure it. Yep.
One purple link, but I always do.
And which will allow us to run a
status as well. We might as well see
what entity think of entity.
Mhmm.
Assuming
it does get restarted by the gateway.
Mhmm.
Alright. We have no.
I wouldn't.
Maybe maybe it's still coming up. I don't
know. I would look at things. I I
didn't do anything here. This should you should
be able to restart everything.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Let's see.
This is actually surprisingly healthy. Like, I like
it when I see node not found, but
it just means they can't. But I would
still like it to start container.
I I don't know if this
rep is capturing.
Maybe try running.
You call again. Never.
Well, let's see what CTR says.
Right. Control.
So,
yeah, two days ago.
Try
Is it not RMP?
Oh, no. It is. It's just telling me
to stop it first.
Because there are two Eat City
running.
Oh, there are. There's one fifty three seconds
ago.
I I think it's running. I I don't
think this
I don't know what this other
That might be a
it's too runny.
If so, that was an accident.
Pures are hard.
These are the same three log files. Something's
Yeah. We do have two.
And there was one seems to be here.
No log.
I mean, I think we just have to
set fire to this machine.
I mean, I don't know where this other
let's kill this other ECT,
but it's not related to the
to the break.
Okay.
Yeah. It's not.
Unless this is a symptom of my break.
But I think from from point of view,
they don't they they shouldn't care about this
one.
No. No. Did the pod ID.
Oh, you
Actually, just stop. Oh, wait. Wait. The Cryoctl
is showing oh, you're doing Cryoctl pods.
Doesn't that always show the pod in the
container?
So let's stop this pod. Let's stop this
pod.
That's the two HCD pods.
Mhmm.
Oh, I think there's a leak pod, but
not a leak container.
If you do get if you do Crysatail
containers
oh, sorry. Just Crysatail LS or PS. LS
or no? Or PS.
Alright. Alright. So this is the new one.
So it looks like it created a new
pod, but
so, like, there's, like, the pod it creates
in the container.
I think it leaked the old pod.
Cool.
But this is a little bit of a
of a side rabbit hole.
Yeah. I I I don't know why
it's it's not starting.
I think it is. If you do if
you do kube cuddle pods, I think it's
Yeah.
We don't have an API server.
We got a Kiplit.
Got a Kiplit. API server is restarting. But
I think if you do that privacy tail
PS again, maybe,
it might or PSA. We'll see if I
y
see, it's saying, oh, it's a new HCD,
not
oh, this is.
So HCD is still not touched. We might
maybe kill it from here.
Okay. Painter ID.
Alright. Well, I might have learned the valuable
lesson here about what not to play with
actually.
Alright. Let's do something we've never done before.
I'm gonna suggest we reboot this box. We
jump over to the other cluster, and we
start tackling that, and we come back to
this one
and hope the reboot gets sent to were
your changes left through a reboot?
No. I don't think so.
Well, yeah.
So
how much do you wanna answer that?
Well,
the changes will not persist, but there might
be something else on the machine that would
rekick it. But I don't think I'd set
that to I don't think on a reboot,
that wouldn't start again.
I don't know what to do about that
zombie process. I think
I I I don't know.
Yeah. I mean, hey. Reboot's fair game. Right?
Do we have any other options?
I mean, we could
try to stop the thing that's causing that
maybe is causing a hang here.
Like, there might be a service here that's
doing something that's maybe just making somebody else
not happy. Right.
Okay. Let's see if we can find that
service.
It's probably named Teleport or something to sort
of disguise itself.
You're good spying things out.
What do you think this is?
Oh, it's real ugly.
Alright.
So we find a malicious actor.
Let's see. For thirty seconds.
It is rather cry control PS. Looking for
it.
Yeah. I think this is maybe related to
our problem.
Alright. What's it doing? It's getting a container
ID.
Ah, right. Okay. So you're modifying your throttle.
Change on the IOPS. So
Yeah. I'm setting an IOPS, and it's per
second limit.
Alright. So we got secrets directly.
There's two things. Right? We can first
tell that script, and, he's not headed in
the system to somewhere. But but
It's a it's a service. You'll have to
you might wanna disable that.
Yeah. The
block IO service,
isn't it?
Oh, it's a little bit down.
Okay.
And let
how do you flush this?
Well, the zombie's gone.
I guess someone I guess holding on to
some file there is is
not making someone happy.
Hey.
Alright.
We may just have to wait for the
API server to come online.
We'll give that a minute. Yeah. That definitely
did fix the NCD then. So you were
you had that script running at the system
you serviced every thirty second. It was changing
the throttle parameters on the the disk IO
too. I'm assuming just zero. Oh, yeah. I
mean, honestly, I just wanted to change them
once, but the problem is, like, there was
no, like well, I guess container d is
adding support for it, but I guess it's,
like, one dot seven or something comes in.
Kubernetes has no support for,
like, IO limits.
So I was like, okay. I could change
it for this one c group. But then
if he just accidentally kills that process, then
it's and he's, you know, he's free. You
know, what's the fun there?
So
figured, like, if we had, like, a service
that could just reset it in case of
the world where, like, you do restart the
pod and then,
you know, a new container would come up.
And, like, for thirty seconds, everything would be
happy, and then the limits be back. But,
clearly, it did a little bit more, harm
there. I guess the script was a little
too hacky.
Kiddos.
But things appear to be getting better.
We do have
a custard pod trying to be scheduled. It's
currently in a pending state. So let's see
if we can take a few more minutes
onto this cluster and get something working. What's
your next step?
Okay. So
let's
check this,
Selium operator that's currently in crash loop.
I would maybe just delete that part. The
other one seems to be healthy.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
I I feel like that's a a red
heading. Although, again,
I'm I'm wrong more than I'm right. But
I
I don't feel that we should worry about
that. Oh, no. The cluster is running. Yep.
So let's call on
port 666.
The
whole the node port is 30,000, but the
cluster Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Alright.
You have v one. Okay.
So v one. Let's
edit the deploy and then
change it to v two.
Cannot be that simple, but
Oh, no. I think I think we're good.
It's terminating the old one.
Mission successful.
Yay.
That's good for us. Oh, man.
I
hate density.
Oh, man. So, yeah, just yeah. I didn't
know. Slow HCD is really just a headache.
It's so hard to figure out, like, when
when that's even the problem. So Yeah. I
I guess slow everything instead of
yeah.
Yeah. It was really weird, though, how,
you know, for the first while, we were
able to see at city running.
We were getting slow responses, and then suddenly
it just kind of
zombied on us. I'm not sure what triggered
that or how that
happened,
but there you go.
Very sneaky.
Alright. Let's see how cruel
Hans has been.
Ready, Zach?
Sorry. I I I think my thing paused
for a second. I
was just saying I hope Hans has been
really cruel. Good luck. Oh,
yeah. I probably deserve it after that one.
Do you want do you want me to
share my screen, or you want you just
wanna type it type continue?
Yeah. If you could share, go for it.
Alright. I'll share my screen.
I I am using Chrome.
Don't tell my employer that I'm not using
Edge for this, but
okay. So you see my screen?
In just a moment. Pop over
here.
I'll quickly duplicate your face. There we go.
Alright.
Got it.
Alrighty.
Can you
Let's start. A window or a desktop?
Desktop. I couldn't figure out window. Do you
want me to do window? I I just
kind of only give me a No. You
can you can do the window, but I'll
just I'm gonna ask you to resize it,
but so it fits in the frame. That's
all.
Oh, sorry.
I don't know how
do I have to stop? Let me share
again.
Oh, it should've been there. Oh, window. There's
a window option.
Here we go.
Okay. That should be better.
Alright. And if you could zoom in three
times.
That's it. Good.
I'd I'd go to one more.
I know it's gonna look
annoying on your site, but, yeah, that looks
good.
Yeah.
Okay. We we may have to just
if you drag the left hand side of
the window to the right
oh, the wrong way. Yep. Wrong way.
Make your window yeah. That that's it. Perfect.
Right there. That's the one.
Good. Hey. Good luck.
Did you bring hands?
No.
Anything I
wait. What did you say, David? I said,
did you break it to d?
No. I did not.
Oh, yeah.
I crashed it back off?
Can
you make your window slightly
smaller vertically?
Just a smidge.
Good.
Audrey, try and make it 16 by nine,
which I know isn't a possible request. But
Did I lose you?
Yeah. We've lost having 10 We've lost the
sides.
What? We've lost the sides.
Like, if you could just I know.
Yeah.
K. Okay. Let's go. That's it.
Don't touch anything.
All done. And now I wanna touch my
keyboard.
Okay. So I was not found, but it
kept positive showing.
Oh, we're doing something funky here.
Oh, no. We're just kind of
Interesting.
So
is the
something
quick here.
Generation
one. What is going on?
So are you touching this?
Two seventy five is pretty high.
Is this going up constantly?
I suspect so.
Yeah.
I think there's an a a trigger.
Let's see.
We got
a lot of time to trigger.
This weird custard is my
favorite and also worst tool that I've
I've never enjoyed and hated something so much.
Yeah. I just remember, like like, looking at
myself this morning being like, why did I
reach out to be in this?
I blame the Ship It podcast. I kinda
wanna check that out. Oh, we got Coverno.
Funny. Yeah. Coverno caused a lot of headaches
for me at my last job on.
Shout out to any of my, accomplished coworkers
on the call. We all know the fun
of Coverno.
My favorite thing about custard is that I
give everybody forty eight hours to break it.
When we look resources, it always says modified
an hour ago. Okay.
This is fun.
Should we just get rid of Coverno?
I wouldn't judge you.
All from a release.
I I just wanna make sure I take
a pair of part to burn it on
the right way, but let's just
Helm list as names based if that help.
Oh,
yeah. Thank you. I I just I guess
I could find the helm release and leave
it properly, but I think I can get
enough of it gone to not cause me
a headache. The finalizer enters enters the chat.
Yeah. Famous last words.
Oh, it it ran away. There you go.
Never seen that before.
Alright.
Well, after if you ever have a cluster
like this to install,
you like, you get, like, scarred from, like,
trying to delete a namespace.
Yeah. I got a special alias now that
deletes finalizers from all objects in the namespace.
Yeah. It's like
like, once you get finally get a
and you say it's finally deleted or You
can do delete dash dash all as a
friendly tip.
Ah,
thank you.
Okay.
I've told no one's my favorite. Got 10
more.
It's 30,000.
Oh, I'm supposed to trust you now?
Just
I just
you could you could say 30,000 and, like,
in my head, like, I'll just type out,
like, the wrong number.
I feel like I'd see it.
Those connections refused.
Alright. So let's let's just recap
here. Right? So Yeah. We jumped at their
cluster.
The pod was definitely rotating regularly.
You think that was a mutated mission controller
and you have parsed kavernal from all existence.
Yeah. I'm actually not sure. Maybe that is
a it's still doing some weird stuff. So,
like, it's possible that was a
a red herring. I don't know. I meant
at least I'm doing what it used to
be doing.
I think that replica set ID is still
changing.
Let's apply patches.
Let's
see.
Although the last applies configuration annotation there that
show
hyperinal integrating.
Yeah.
An AppSec profile.
Oh,
why is back
up?
Oh, boy.
Who is who is adding this Kiburno again?
I swear I'm I'm not in a machine
and doing something.
That would be evil. Sneaky. So
is there, like, a is there, like, a
boxer controller or, like, a controller that's installed?
No. Don't see anything.
The Hans controller.
People on my Discord have suggested that we
run a Twitter controller so that people could
tweet at a bot and it runs commands
at the cluster.
I've not been feeling that brave yet.
Okay. Might do something nuclear here.
Looks like not nuclear. I just might go
into I might turn on audit logging.
Let's get the.
Is that I'm trying to think if that's,
like, too much.
It's like
because I I have a little I don't
really know who the heck it's doing.
Man, I could try this.
I just hope.
Yeah. I might do that.
Alright. So something is causing Kiberna to come
back. There's no controller in the cluster.
So the thought process here is something on
the host.
It would well, it could be other hosts
too. Right?
I if anyone that has visibility in this
API server
so I I
and I could I
I mean, the other two nodes don't have
permissions to talk to the API servers. Oh,
they okay. Gotcha. I mean, they can subscribe
to the API server and the Kubel can
run pods, but they can't create workloads unless
someone has tampered with that too. But
yeah, I don't think he's done that.
And that was a good good suggestion, David.
Looking on the host. Was a suggestion?
Let's say I I did consider using a
service, but
they are spot on that something is causing
Corona to come back.
Let's let's list all let's all
processes.
I'm
just, like, Is
it p s aux without the dash? Or
You can do either r. Yes. Okay. There.
Sounds but why not?
I mean, I would think, like, what I
always find telling, right, is that the things
people debug in the other cluster are usually
things related to what they've done themselves. So
think about what Hans' questions were early on
in your cluster.
You mess with
oh, no. You did.
Probably what you suggested.
Sort of end up becoming completely paranoid. Was
at least sort of my all of these
things going through my head, debugging that, oh,
what is can I trust this command? Can
I trust output here?
Trust nothing.
Yeah. Trust nothing.
Did oh, did he rename something?
That would be sneaky.
But I think you I
I think you've already I think you're the
trigger, if that helps.
Yeah.
So let's see if I just now use
this for that one.
When does this come back?
Yeah. It comes back.
And so you use the service to sort
of keep it running. Right, Zach?
I think I use something else.
Yeah.
I'm trying to I mean, I just need
to
You trust skip control?
No. I think there's just something. Maybe the
cron job or something.
I just wanna get all
I just wanna get all the processes.
Why am I not why is TX aux
aux not showing everything?
It doesn't understand.
Am I?
What's what's
up with the whatever session I'm in?
I'm
Try what? That's weird.
But
what I just do?
Oh, I just got
oh, Just did and that's enter.
Tell me your I have your your session
back.
Oh, yeah. I didn't notice that behavior earlier.
I just created the session on hands control
point one and run PSE UX and see
the interesting output. That's funny.
I think I know what that is.
I'm sorry. Yeah.
Just open a new session.
Yeah.
I don't think PS is PS.
Try running
type p s.
Wait. Let's see. He messed up he messed
up the actual p s,
but
no. Because,
like, I would see something in top of
this.
I would start check
the bash RC. I mean, this has gotta
be a function or an alias. Right?
Or what can it be if if it's
not out of those?
Oh, you enabled control completion. That was very
nice. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you.
But you are on on the sort of
the right hand share that PS is not
necessarily PS. Yeah. It could just be a
script. Right?
Oh, man. It's already in your trap.
Alright.
What are we doing here?
Quite funny.
K. So you're
I mean, PS
should be a bash button. Right? So you
you can probably just remove that script altogether.
Yeah. You can just move the PSS to
PS,
and then you're good.
Let's remove this.
Yeah. No. You you just move move user
bin PSS
to user bin PS to rename it.
Is PSS not built in? No. I I
guess I guess not. Okay.
There
we go. I was losing my mind for
a second. I was like, is is is
AUX not what gets all processes?
Now now now I'm just looking in the
in the field for whoever is doing something
bad. Oh,
okay. So we
Are we doing a?
But you did you did mention something earlier,
Zach, something about Cron.
What did you
But I'm not sure if it show up
on the process list, though. Right.
You can do CronTap dash e.
Did I mess with CronTap?
No.
I I did I did consider sort of
messing with CronTab as well to sort of
remove when you're sort of viewing. But
Yeah. It does not appear to be a
Cron job.
Or but can you run a cron job
without it being in cron tab?
Yes.
I just I just, like, disabled your guide.
Okay. Did you I'm gonna I don't know
if you copied off the
You could disable the current service and the
ATD service if you don't want any of
these jobs to run.
Oh, okay. Or you could just, yeah, break
his access with the admin comp. I think
both would be pretty successful.
Unless I've copied the credentials.
I know. I know. I I I was
that's that's what this Let's rotate the search.
Come on.
Yeah.
Well, that this would be a good point.
Let's see Kubernetes had replication.
You know? Server application.
Could be okay.
I would stop a
t d as well.
What's what's that a? A t d. They
are demon.
I still wanna break them up.
Okay. Pass the back off.
Bye bye.
At least it's not changing anymore.
But
it depends whether that was modifying the pod
or the deployment. You may find this added
something to the deployment that you need to
purge.
I'm assuming we maybe have a last applied
annotation on this.
Maybe
not.
It's what what is this error?
Never even got to the bottom of that.
Well, I thought it was the
app armor or second profile being added by.
But maybe I'm wrong.
Oh, we probably need to
I would have to kill this. So let
get roll out now without
modifying that.
If, yeah, if Kibarno modified the pod, then
deleting the pod should Oh, we got some
Valve in the webhooks too.
You're Go developer, Zach?
I am a Go developer.
What? You're single dashes.
Yeah.
Oh, no. I just you know, I'm a
when when typing on on livestream,
every single keystroke I manage to get correct
is is surprising to me.
Alright.
I think you're gonna have to take a
look at that deployment.
Wow. Look at all those.
Oh, we got it.
Or describe the pod and see what the
header message is. I
can kill this one.
Just receive a code. Keep it.
It doesn't log anything.
Right. I'm sorry.
No.
I guess It's running, so your curl may
work there.
Not quite.
Yeah. It's hanging.
Oh, man. There we met.
It should be running on port 666.
And
there should be an IP table rule to
forward 30,000
There's nothing 30,000
here.
Maybe not. Actually, I can't remember if QIP
proxy runs in these clusters or whether I
would feel silly and remember.
There's a golden rule of running get services,
and you never run get services on its
own.
Call my EP. I mean, anyone at least
has service on its own is is a
braver person than I am.
Right.
It looks good. I think I think it
should work.
Does it have the does this local host
have to work? Oh, wait. Wait. Where
is it scheduled?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I would try the the 10 dot
IP address there. Yeah. You could use the
cluster IP if you need to. Yeah.
Here we go. Okay. Use the cluster.
But then it's 666,
right, on that IP? It should still be.
I have it as the 30000.
Alright.
Cluster
networking.
And this this should have worked by now.
If you do, keep control get nodes dash.
I was gonna I'm also gonna go into
one of these other nodes and see what's
happening.
Yeah. You
can run local host 30,000 on that.
But I am not Because it's a worker
node that should work.
I don't know if this is if it's
scheduled on this one.
Yeah. The the north port should have parked,
though.
That's two.
Yeah. I don't think it's working because I've
just tried it externally and it's not
Oh, it is. It's just very slow.
Oh. Because Yeah. It is. Database failure. Oh,
database look up. So
we're getting a time out. A failed to
look up address information on the database.
Okay.
So we messed up the database.
I guess that was fair game.
Let's go back.
Just because you didn't open that in a
browser, the error message is failed to look
up address, temporary failure, and name resolution.
Gotcha. So okay. Working as
is is the application reaching it's reaching out
through
Kubernetes service? It is. It uses Postgres as
a service name. It's hard coded on the
app.
Okay.
This looks okay.
It does look okay. Yep.
How else can traffic within the cluster be
manipulated?
Yeah. Both database and DNS, it's
should be running fine.
Yeah. There's a lot of ways to to
do that.
That's it.
What's this
eDNS?
Trust AP
option.
I don't know it.
I deleted.
If it's a DNS specific problem, then
you should still be able to communicate
directly with
IPs. I'm not sure what's inside the container,
if there's anything like curl or something to
test that.
I
I changed the is it is it it's
hard coded, the It's hard coded. It's off
to Postgres.
I would maybe look for network policy.
Or just NetPol for short.
There's also CNPs and CCMPs
because it's a Cilium cluster.
CnP?
That's the Cilium network policies and CCN. Cilium.
And
excuse me.
Silly and policy.
Yeah. That's a silly cluster wide network policy,
which is blocking all Ethers traffic.
Oh. From the cluster pod.
That's pretty easy.
And your favorite to the alt command?
Hey.
Let's see if we can get this upgraded
to v two.
Something not happy about now.
Well
yeah. Good luck.
Back.
V two already present on machine.
Oh, man.
This is this is the last one,
and then you're home free.
K. That's good.
Oh, wow. You shrunk my image for me
down to nine meg. I'd love to know
how you did that.
Probably.
That image with a 200 meg video in
it. I don't know how you got that
to nine meg.
Magic.
You may find it easier just to do
image cool policy always from the control plane.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. That's your fault.
So what is the name MegaMhans?
Oh, it's just a single
go binary that just
stops
and just has some error message if you
have if you would have been looking at
the logs to just throw it off. Yeah.
Up five more lanes. That's it there. Yeah.
If not present. Oh,
yes.
Now
do we need it?
Pull it out. Yeah.
You'll just do just oh, I think it's
fixed. Oh, it's ta da.
Hey.
Well done.
It's fun.
Alright. These are both very cruel people.
Lots of of of lots of cool breaks
there.
Yeah. The one was really funny when it
kept coming back.
It's like the convert because, like, from the
dead. You know? Yeah.
Is always not bad, like, and they're just
like, it's back.
But, yeah, I can't find the Etsy break
Etsy brief. I never we never got the
answer. How how were you hosting
the
It's the
Chrome
CronD directory,
and it doesn't show up when you do
use the Chrome tab.
There you go.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you both for, a, taking
time to break cluster, which I know is
is not easy. It takes effort and time
to think about how to do it and
to actually apply it, and we see some
really fun breaks today. And, again, I hope
we never see entity again.
But,
also, for joining me live
in front of an audience and being vulnerable
enough to try and fix some clusters. So
I really appreciate both of you taking the
time to do that. Thank you again.
Hopefully, you know, maybe we'll see you back
again in the future. But for now, I'll
say thank you very much. I'll say thank
you to Equinix and to Teleport and to
everyone watching. Any last words, Hans or Zach,
before we finish?
It just reminds me how much I hate
hate
it's a city.
So kudos hats to you, Zach.
Really, really clever. Really enjoyed it.
Yeah.
Yeah. No. Yeah. This is a lot of
fun. And I I love I love seeing
Caverno in the center of it. I really
love Caverno, actually. It's it's really it's really
great.
So it's good shout out to them. But,
yeah, that's a lot of fun, Briggs. This
was fun. I enjoyed this. Alright. Thought it
would.
Alright. Well, thank you both again. I'll speak
to you soon, and to everyone watching. Have
a great day.